there's nothing worse than watching a
trailer for an upcoming movie you're
excited about only to realize halfway
through that the trailer is giving away
the entire plot and it isn't just a
modern problem either marketing
companies have been putting major
spoilers and trailers for years let's
take a look at some trailers that
totally ruin the movie and well spoilers
ahead
obviously last house on the left the
trailer for 2009 s Last House on the
Left leaves no surprise unspoiled as it
bounces through the entire script in the
space of two and a half minutes we learn
that two young women have an unfortunate
run-in with fugitives who then execute
one and leave the other one in a lake as
they look for a place to hide overnight
the gang ends up at the lake house of
the girl they shot if the trailer had
stopped there it would have been pretty
good unfortunately it goes on to show
the surviving girl making at home and
her parents exacting the revenge on the
criminals including the literal final
scene of the movie there's really no
point even watching it now you know
everything that happens cast away it may
be one of Tom Hanks most celebrated
roles but anyone who saw the trailer for
castaway promptly had the entire plot
spoiled for them in the preview were
shown the plane-crash Hanks character
survives and his arrival on the island
where he's stranded standard trailer
stuff really makes you wonder if the guy
survives huh well just keep watching the
trailer it shows Hanks character
building a raft and writing a note
detailing how long he'd been on the
island even worse it inexplicably tells
us that he survives this harrowing
journey and makes it back home the
castaway trailer is also another one of
those previews that uses the last shot
of the movie as the last shot of the
trailer so there are literally no
surprises left thanks for ruining
everything
trailer editors
yep even that shutter island' when the
first trailer for shutter island was
released Paramount Pictures didn't
bother to hide much of the plot in fact
the trailer pretty neatly summarized the
entire thing it becomes evident early on
that the disappearance of rachel solando
is not the real mystery here but the
existence of an unknown 67th patient at
the mental institution and the quickly
accelerating deterioration of the main
character's grip on reality thankfully
the trailer left the big super twisty
twist at the end intact for film goers
but at that point you could pretty much
forget about enjoying the ride the sum
of all fears the trailer for Ben
Affleck's debut as Jack Ryan and 2002 s
the sum of all fears is a lesson in how
not to do a trailer for a spy felt this
clip sets up the main threat early on
while Affleck and Morgan Freeman be able
to track down the missing Russian
scientist before they can build a
nuclear bomb and use it in the US that
sounds like an intriguing plot and might
have drawn a casual viewer to see the
movie unfortunately the trailer then
destroys all the suspenseful build-up by
showing the bombs detonation the rest of
the story where Ryan keeps the president
from wrongly retaliating against Russia
seems like a major letdown after such a
big reveal Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice naturally there were several
trailers for 2016 s mega movie Batman
vs. Superman dawn of Justice but with
the second promo trailer the studio
apparently decided to just give away the
entire plot and hope fans were too
devoted to the brand to care the trailer
makes no mystery of most of the critical
plot points with scenes in order and all
the major beats revealed lex luthor
introduces Bruce Wayne and Clark Kent
then manipulates them both to get them
to fight the two superheroes Duke it out
for a while which is in the title so
that's fine until surprise here's
doomsday to fight them but wait who
appears to save the day why it's Wonder
Woman and the duel becomes a trio
working together to battle the bad guy
and save the world despite all the
spoilers the movie made over 870 million
at the worldwide box office so
apparently the strategy paid off final
destination
all the films in the final destination
series are pretty bad about putting huge
spoilers in their trailers
while we know the entire premise of the
movies revolves around the demise of
people who cheated faith spoiling the
characters comeuppance in the trailers
pretty much defeats the purpose in the
trailer for the first final destination
movie alone we get to see Todd miss
Luton and Billy meet their gruesome
fates later installments in the
franchise are similarly spoilery usually
revealing the demise of at least a third
of the cast along the way Kingsman the
Golden Circle in 2014's Kingsman the
Secret Service Colin Firth's character
Harry Hart is shot in the face by
Valentine it's implied that Hart is out
of the picture
with eggsy taking over his role within
the Kingsmen spy organization with the
first official trailer for the Golden
Circle the Fox marketing team decided to
spoil a huge secret in the final seconds
of the trailer
this revelation didn't set well with
director Matthew Vaughn who said I
begged the studio not to reveal it
because it's the whole driving force at
the first act and if you didn't know
that scene it would have made the whole
audience gasp apparently the marketing
guys didn't take the hint because the
second trailer for the Golden Circle
even showed Harry in action along with a
reveal of Julianne Moore's character as
the big bad Friday the 13th
although the 1980 horror film Friday the
13th eventually went on to become a
massive box-office success and spawned
an entire franchise the trailer for the
movie definitely didn't do it any favors
in typical ad style the trailer for
Friday the 13th has a voiceover but this
time the marketing team at Paramount
didn't bother trying to entice audiences
with a mysterious backstory or synopsis
instead they just showed every
character's demise while the voice-over
counts them not only does the trailer
have no qualms about spoiling every
twist in the movie it also takes a weird
turn in counting up to the 13 in the
title the trailer implies there will be
12 casualties during the film but there
were actually only 10 denying victims
and Pamela Voorhees herself so much for
truth in advertising thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to